manquait plus que ça
rosine mario à je la voyais pas comme ça
exactement mais bon bah c'est à peu près
pareil mais un truc qui est pas pareil
oui c'est la version colorisée un peu
voilà quand je vois une dame comme ça
j'ai tout de suite eu envie de me
gratter les peaux pièce que cette bonne
il a tendance à se gratter un peu les
paupiettes que les grottes non c'est pas
la peine je veux jouer mais
je vais m'en sorte non mais ça va en
sortir
non c'est pas possible je serais curieux
quand même de devoir la rencontre entre
entre madame ou mademoiselle je sais pas
si vous êtes esprits en plus chez banco
requête et et maria bodin ça ça peut
valoir le jus merci beaucoup y'a pas de
quoi passer d'entrée ce cas allez à
bientôt puis tu peux passer le coup de
balai un sassafras
ça me maintient au niveau du dos